so today I'd like to talk about
attacking a color complex which is sort
of a more specific part of the very
broad area of attacking chests and I
still remember back when I was a kid
growing up a club level player I'll say
of my range of say 1400 to 2100 which is
obviously a massive range I kind of had
one mo which was way too a little bit on
castling capsule on the other side that
the other guy did and just sort of throw
upon some hope for the best and this
really worked well for a while it was a
very simplistic caveman approach that
was quite effective for quite some time
but eventually as I encountered stronger
and stronger defense I found that
there's a lot more to playing chess than
just attacking and there's a lot more to
attacking than just throwing pawns and
as I got more mature I became more
positional and I was still playing
dynamic chess but I had things in my
arsenal other than just attack and then
I kind of got to thinking why is it that
we don't see any of these top players
you know attacking if you think recently
uh Magnus Carlsen face to f3
nimzo-indian four times he's got three
and a half points out of four with black
and this is the attacking opening it
seems like all the time you see kind of
at the very highest level attacking has
gone down but when I started to really
look at the way they attack when it
happens and I started to analyze the
games of very strong players whose main
mo is sort of play for the initiative
and the attack foot soo that really
comes to mind or Alexander gristick
whose game I'm gonna be presenting today
and Judith Pulgar those are a couple who
you should really be looking at you want
to fall attacking chess so we're talking
about attacking a color complex which is
very different than just sort of
throwing pawns and the game I'd like to
show today is one of my very favorites
it's a game between Alexander gristick
playing white and Boris Gelfand playing
black at the 2010 Linares tournament
started opens with d4 d5 later Knight f6
sorry c4 e6 so we got some nimzo-indian
I'm not gonna comment too much about the
opening because it's largely outside the
scope of this lecture
but you had some Rubinstein variation
castles should do three this is all
still following her main lines c5 Knight
f3 a5 castle so now it is there's two
pretty common systems one involving a
knight c6 here and oftentimes black will
end up taking the night and playing with
Queen c7 85 and the other is the Karpov
variation where he takes twice in the
center in place p6 but uh Gelfand played
sort of a more old main line which is I
guess it's appropriate because it was
more main back then which is D takes c4
bishop takes c4 Knight bt7
okay this has gone out of popularity now
but it remains the very playable option
for black I'm not gonna comment too much
but now Gris trick plays plenty too
and I remembered reading some commentary
about this game where it said it's very
hard to pinpoint where gelfand went
wrong and when I first saw this game as
an IM I couldn't understand at all where
Gelfand went wrong but with a more
mature understanding now I think his
next one was inaccurate and that is the
MU basics so black has a very clear plan
at this movie wants to play b5 in
developers Bishop but the problem is the
only real way for him to develop this
Bishop is to b7 there's not really any
other way to do it comfortably and now
gross trick responds with a very strong
move a4 and essentially black wool he
plays b6 and develops as Bishop to b7
the inclusion of these moves a 4 and a 6
of drastically limited blacks potential
because of the hanging Conan a6 this
rook will always have to be stuck
protecting it it's very hard to lend any
more support and playing a5 will create
a big hole on the b v square and lead to
some issues so nowadays people are
mainly actually playing b6 in this
position and okay not sure i should
really be devil think too much about the
opening but i think blacks they're more
or less okay you know after a 6 a 4 at
this point Gelfand decided to develop
his pieces in a different manner so he
captured on d4 let you takes d4 now 96
so the first point of order here is what
we often see in isolated Queens pawn
positions is a real debate on where to
put the
slide square bishop in a lot of cases
you want it on d3 where it influences
the kingside and in a lot of cases
you'll see it on b3 where you try to
crash through with d4 d5 and put more
pressure so it's like a pole I let's
wait for 30 seconds so I'm gonna take a
pull show of hands who's gonna want
which one so you've got 25 more seconds
think it over and come up with the
square you want so basically in this
specific case there's two main reasons
one we put the bishop on b3 one the
biggest one would be to try to put more
pressure on this breakthrough d4 d5
another would be to lunge protection to
this pawn with rook to e1 and not have
to worry about the bishop in the way but
the somewhat unusual position of the
knight nb6 when normally it would be on
c6
it's a position like this changes
everything with the knight on c6 I would
say we want the bishop on this diagonal
so we can support the pawn with the rook
and crush through with the night on b6
black does not have any pressure on this
pawn but he does have the d5 square
while under control so in this case
Bishop d3 is the proper course of action
what doesn't have to worry about
anything on d4 and he can just sort of
pursue the Kings side it well so this is
a relatively typical isolated Queens
pawn but I think the night on b6 is a
little bit inferior so I would say why
it's a little bit better here so with
that I am b6 not being the best gulp and
quite naturally continued with Knight to
d5 and exchanged which was a little bit
counterintuitive because in general when
you're playing with the isolated queen
pawn did those ideas beside with the iqp
should be avoiding exchanges on the side
who has the iCube you should be trying
to go for them but we're actually seeing
something very concrete here's the black
doesn't really have a great way to take
back in light of how the game progressed
I would suggest an improvement ethics t5
and I think White's a little bit better
here after a move like 95 he's a little
bit more developed his pieces are taking
more active posts and he's got it's
easier for him to sink this Knight into
the e5 outpost than for black to do
anything similar on e4 nonetheless
blacks position remains solid it's gonna
be hard to break down I I think this
would have offered
gelfand better chances in light of what
we saw shortly Queen 65 looks nice
developing any piece for that it's a
hard time meeting bishops
five there's a very unpleasant threat
through and blacks palm structure and
it's quite hard to deal with the Queen
can quickly find herself stranded in the
center so and the game Gelfand made the
most natural recapture with Knight 65 so
restrict plague 24 and okay this move is
it seems very simplistic just trying to
attack this checkmate it's almost a move
I would play when I was 800 just saying
okay maybe he wants you to mate but it's
also a very deep move and the best move
it's quite uncomfortable for black to
defend this pawn so he has three ways to
not lose the game immediately he can
play f5 Knight f6 or g6 which we played
in the game okay f5 is just really
asking for a trouble at this point White
has all the normal pluses of an isolated
Queen fine position but in addition to
that he has the e5 square and this week
e6 pawn which will make this Bishop very
passive at this point White's pawn
structure is no worse than black and he
still has all the good piece activities
so why would just be clearly better
Knight f6 looks very natural to put more
pressure on the open D file and develop
but after Queen h4 it's funny but what
is this simple threatening played Bishop
g5 removed the defender and then take on
HSN with a checkmate very simple and
it's a it's not even if this moves right
it's a move after this move threat but
ironically black has absolutely no
defense it's kind of funny because h6 at
any moment with the bishop on g5 or on
c1 will always be met by Bishop takes h6
with a completely crushing attack and
black just has absolutely no way to deal
with this problem with Bishop g5 so if
he's reduced to playing a move like g6
I'm not sure exactly what the most
direct way forward is but somehow this
pin on the saggin all should end the
game in short order so this would not be
good instead of that
Dothan pledged e6 voluntarily so I just
leaving the knight on d5 but not walking
into the pen Chris trick was very
natural move Bishop h6 perky eight I
need to just bring in more pieces in 95
oh this seems pretty simple and
straightforward I don't think these are
wildly difficult moves to understand or
to even come up with over the board
Queen f3 now at this point I read some
notes after the game I think wrist
tricks suggested f6 here which it looks
very dangerous after allowing white to
sacrifice on g6 but it's not clear but Y
can play a very very silent and brutal
attacking move Queen g3 which actually
just immediately ends the game which I
thought was kind of funny black just has
absolutely no defense to the pursuing
massacre on g6 if he plays something
like g5 well we don't need to analyze
this very deeply I don't think so f6 was
it was suggested but it's not really an
improvement so black plays Queen e7 at
this one we're gonna stop and take stock
of the situation the battle lines have
been drawn why does the isolated queen
pawn and he has a quite nice attacking
setup his pieces seem to be well placed
but it's difficult to see how he's gonna
bring the rest of his army into the
attack it's difficult to see where the
real weakness is to make headway our and
what Chris truck came up with here was
almost brilliant ideas I'd ever seen so
I'll leave it to the audience to see if
you guys can come up with a way to
increase the pressure for white yes its
force the second best move that's the
one that I would have played myself what
I was watching over this game so h4
would suggest it's very natural it kind
of goes back to the sort of caveman
style of play I was describing for my
own style as when I was young white
wants to h5 and start stacking stuff it
seems pretty clear but after f6 blocks a
bit more prepared to deal with any and
sueing sacrifices and y could try 966
it's a bit speculative but it may be
it's not so bad
probably he can just play something like
Knight 67 Queen 67 h5 and I would I
would slightly prefer white but after f5
it's not that easy to break through a
black king will be reasonably safe on f7
he can rewrite the bishop to
both exchange an attacker or if it goes
away to come to g7 to defends I I would
still slightly prefer white here somehow
but it's and it's the move I would have
played when I saw this game at almost a
twenty five hundred level player but why
does something better so sorry okay
Bishop e4 has been suggested which was
played it's a very nice move
so why it's just increasing the pressure
he's threatening to win upon and the
knight moves to that b7 hanging but
black wool very happily respond with
Bishop c6 and he's not really worried
about losing the bishop pair because it
would solidify his control over g5 and
white would exchange off very valuable
attacker and that structure with the
pawn back on a2 or something it might be
a little better for I with upon a poor
it gives a really nasty be file with a
lot of weaknesses so Knight 66 doesn't
really affect change much doesn't really
help light so okay we've you've improved
your bishop and I've improved mine
how does white then continue this is the
real star move of the game should be
five if I take it to you checkmating me
I don't think so and the Queen takes yet
I can take what the bishop is very nice
to avoid the fork yeah
yeah Bishop g5 I do think I can get away
with taking it yes
Wow had a real barbarian here I like it
but uh I don't think that why does I
need meaning full compensation for the
piece here I think he just sort of
exchanged off a really good attacker but
keep up the aggression I like it need a
little bit more refinement that players
of Chris tricks level can show us h4
yeah we discussed that at a couple
minutes ago h4 is the second best move
and it leads to maybe a slight advantage
for white but uh it's got something much
more effective drivers it doesn't really
achieve that much I'll give you guys a
hint
I remember the theme of this lecture the
title is attacking a color complex yes
it's kind of retreating the night a 93
has been suggested it kind of brings the
night away from where the real action is
on the Kings side so basically to help
you guys come with this decision
where are the weaknesses here black has
all these weaknesses around his King yes
f5 loses a piece yeah but let's start
off by before move so let's look where
the weaknesses in blacks King position
dark squares so you've got f6 is a
weakness maybe have sevens the weakness
what pieces do we have they're attacking
these key dark squares
yeah yeah I've got a bishop on h6 this
night could be ready to come to g4 it
doesn't work now but someone suggested
the idea Queens come and the Queen could
help support have sex and what peace
cannot influence the dark squares at all
right and what piece is defending f6
enough for all the other important dark
squares I suggest to move Bishop 65
which I know I don't remember who
annotated this game when I saw it but
they didn't give an exclamation point to
it so I'll compensate by giving to this
was just a brilliant move this whole
concept bringing this black Bishop from
c8 to d5 was just activating giving him
a beautiful bishop pair it seems so anti
positional but after we have four we're
already seeing right now black has
immediate and direct problems with his
dark squares Knight g4 is a colossal
threat this bishop on d5 looks nice but
it's really not doing very much
it doesn't help defend the Kings side
this Bishop on b4 is offside if the
Queen's disappeared why it would
probably be significantly worse but as
is with the Queen's on the board is
attacking chances are much better than
any positional consideration I can think
of and already with 94 being a huge
problem blacks put under a lot of
pressure and he has to make a very
difficult decision here now Gilpin
played the move f5 directly trying to
prevent Knight g4 I don't think this was
the best move I would have preferred
Bishop d6 but even there I understand
that White's gonna have better chances
and at this point blacks having to make
a judgment call based on two positions
where it's clearly under pressure and
this is where you can see a player if
kelvins level make perhaps an inaccuracy
it's still open for debate after my
preferred move Bishop d6 white would
certainly play Bishop g5 and after
something like Queen c7 or Queen f8
we're gonna install this Bishop on f6
and White has very serious attacking
chances he's not giving checkmate just
yet but it's it's very very dangerous
for black and we can expect the well I
don't think Chris trick wood will be
holding anything back here so instead
though kelvins just decided he wanted
nothing to do with this weakness on f6
and plate f5 so this means the bishop
can't install itself their comfort
because there's always gonna be pressure
on the F file and the knight can't get
there however by doing this he's put
more pawns on light squares and made
more darks for problems so now how
should we continue the attack
I've heard this move before but in this
new position it's correct
yeah I've heard h4 now from a few people
absolutely so white is gonna basically
blow up in this hole Kings side and we
see this from about 5:00 which was made
to defend the dark squares has made more
problems on this week g6 square so black
players were kc8 looking for his counter
play and this was another part of the
game where I was very impressed with
Chris Turks play so how do I continue
did you just play h5 and go nuts or does
he wait for a better moment and there's
some concrete calculation involved but
it's largely a positional consideration
so who wants to go h5 and who wants to
be a little bit more attainable
a boring lecture if I'm just gonna talk
to in a room that's silent it's an
interaction all right show of hands who
wants h5 who wants another move see the
most energetic players want h5 and the
highest rated players want other moves
so uh yeah at this point h5 um would be
a little premature
after h5 ironically I think black can
actually just take this pawn and the
problem is what this did was open the G
file but I think black is actually much
more prepared to take advantage of that
than white and two moves King h8 rook
sure it's going to happen covering all
these weaknesses and then g2 will be a
problem g2 will be met by h4 I think we
can ask a very valid question who is
attacking pou and I would say the answer
is black stack and white so while h5 is
a great idea at this point the threat is
still stronger than the execution and
whites better off with another move so
Chris trick just played calm and simple
with rook a to c1 and again it's another
one of those slightly counterintuitive
moose because you don't want to be
exchanging pieces but at this point
black doesn't really have the means to
exchange rooks because if you would
let's suppose he carries out the
positionally favourable idea he has no
way to retake the C file and already
white might have moves like 966 in the
air followed by Brooks e7 and a major
attacking chances and black doesn't
really have an answer to he doesn't he
can play Bishop d6 but then how does he
how does he ever take the C file back
it's very difficult so blacks unable to
really exchange rooks just yet I mean
he'd like to do it someday one he can
contest to see file more effectively but
yeah so Bishop d6 and at this point
Chris took quite another very nice move
rook after you won so his point with
this move is he needs h5 to work in
order to bring his initiative to a
conclusion for that to happen he's gonna
have to take the G file and it's obvious
he feels like lifting a rook so but it's
tough because black is contesting his
open file work c3 will end up getting
taken so with this move he's preparing
for rook c3
I'll play rook c3 and then when black
takes it he will have shut down the C
file which is black source of counter
play they can come in with the other
rook
so go for it so that's what we see
happen Queen f6 from Galpin which is
just the natural enough move and that
rook c3 okay I believe Gelfand should
have played Bishop before here which
will orchestrate an exchange of rooks I
think it's the best offensive chance
still after something like rook takes c8
and Rick c1 if if we exchange all the
rooks Black has a very difficult time
defending is C file which is one of the
big reasons to lower the bish go away
before exchanging the rooks and I still
think black centre is some very clear
pressure here but I think it's better
than how the game continued so after
rook c3 Galpin captured which prevents
any unpleasant rook swings to g3 and
here you play tricks c8 so this attacks
the c3 pawn and I was preparing for some
counter play so we've played a largely
strategic game up to this point but now
the nature of the position is changing
it's it's really a time to start
calculating so at this point why that's
a very tempting moves but only one
that's best so you guys try to calculate
some lines and see if you can figure out
what should play here yeah so rook c4
has been suggested which will pin this
pawn to the on the fourth rank and
potentially come up for the a pond and
one problem with lifting a rook in
general is that doesn't give your King
much room now this isn't really an issue
right now because the black rook can't
come to the back rank but if a black
rook shows up on a4 that will be an
issue so we've got three ideas from
black here rep 63 rook c4 and Bishop e7
and at the same time with one act with
one move we can stop all three of these
moves and continue our attack so how
should we continue
yes Bishop g5 has been suggested well it
stops a lot of ideas but the bishop was
quite nice on h6 and it's kind of a
retreating move now when we play h5
it'll take longer to use the open G file
the king is no longer in the crosshairs
so it's not quite the most incisive yes
okay ninety seven that's right now we're
starting to calculate I like the idea
but I think concretely this doesn't work
black looks captured the Queen and then
after Knight takes f6 check King's f7
we've got some stuff hanging after
Knight takes d5 Bishop takes h6 White's
completely lost they've got an equal
clones position but c3 is about to fall
and he'll be left with a terrible
structure and down upon it should be
should be completely lost and if we
instead there to capture the bishop on
f4 after king takes f6 I think black has
no problems and in fact you can probably
play for an advantage based on the weak
bonds on the Queen side so this 97
tactic is a very good idea to have in
mind and in fact it's very relevance and
we'll see but this time it was incorrect
in its execution
okay so Queen g3 this is an excellent
move so first of all we're defending
this pawn so obviously blacks not going
to take it the other another idea we
heard of as the defensive try is Bishop
to e7 but now this will probably be
extremely effectively met by Bishop c5
and after say Queen f8 we'll play h5 I
think blacks about to die so we've been
able to break through effectively so
stop the Bishop e7 idea we've stopped
work takes c3 but most importantly what
happens in the event of rooks c4 looking
for counter play
why does a very nice move here we
concretely calculate it this is what we
see when you got guys like Chris Rick
and girlfriend and 2700 and Beyond
playing they have all these brilliant
positional ideas but they supplement
that with very precise calculation and
gross trick no doubts all I work see for
was incorrect or not working for black
any takers
yes okay so in this case the 97 is very
different with the Quint than with the
Quinn f4 because if black is to capture
the Queen we no longer have a hanging
bishop on h6 here after Knight takes f6
check King f7 and 965 White's simply a
piece ahead so this would leave white
with a completely wedding position
however after a 97 the mood best be
calculated as Queen e7 and very good
knight f6 so at this point if black were
to move the King we're gonna again take
this Bishop and after Bishop takes g3
night 67 y is again up a piece so that's
a big problem
it's just occurring to me now after
Bishop takes it for the night straps I
should have done better homework gonna
overlook that probably d5 still very
good for white oh yeah this this is a
very nice resource so Knight f6 check
and now if black were to take the knight
Queen takes d6 what's happened is we've
exchanged our 95 for blacks dark squared
Bishop and with the dark squares being
as weak as they are White's immediately
crashing through Queen B 8 is basically
checkmate and threatened right now so
blacks only defense to that is rook c8
and after Queen d7 we've got serious
problems it looks like this rook was
getting all nice and active with the
rooks e4 move but now the only move for
black to not lose the game immediately
it's rook to a8 which is a pretty sad
move he plays something like we're d8
after Queen c7 Bishop g5 is threatened
and otherwise when black plays let's say
rook e8 to stop it will simply crash
through with c4 and d5 and once so the
rook enters the attack as well it's it's
time to give up so basically if black is
reduced to moves like rook e8 so that
after Queen c7 preparing c4 he can meet
with Queen f7
without hanging a rook if he's reduced
to moves like this we know that we're
doing
really well and that's here okay why it
doesn't have a direct force swim but I
think strategically the games more or
less over so that would be that was a
really nice tactical resource that Chris
trick bounce I realized it's Quinn g3
because if you just continue with a
nonchalant move like rookie three which
seems very consistent to prepare H five
after works before already I wonder if I
can even equalize to something like H
five here's Bishop takes e5 and if rook
takes rook takes c3 and otherwise the
Queen's are exchanged rook g3 again
Bishop takes e5 the Queen's are
exchanged it's alright it's very
difficult for white he doesn't have the
97 where we saw scepter Bishop takes f4
and I takes f6 check King f7 put this on
the board again again after the whole
Knight takes d5 idea there's hanging
stuff in this case for Bishop takes h6
looks like White's losing material
immediately so but not Bishop takes c3
it's important that after Knight takes
c3 it's not so clear rook takes a four
maybe black still ones with the pawns
but Bishop takes h6 was good enough so
it was really well spotted by gross trip
to see that this Queen g3 which in my
opinion was a little counterintuitive
because I thought that white really
should be trying to put the rook on g3
instead of the Queen what concrete
calculation shows it's not possible yet
and that's that so here go back here
several annotators suggested this was a
moment for Gelfand to improve I would
agree but it's even still up to the
suggested improvement it's no cakewalk
for black and that's Bishop takes e5 and
at least here we're forcing this white
pawn on c5 which will prevent the Queen
from taking the dark squares after
something like takes gonna play Queen e7
and the idea will be to after h5 try to
run with the King nonetheless after hg 6
hg 6 Bishop g5 I think quite clearly has
a very powerful initiative and it
probably he's a bit better objectively
but practically much better it's gonna
be quite difficult to defend this from
so still that was probably the lesser
evil kelvins sort of thought it's a
really flutter of it here and he played
there should be four which has some
merit trying to block the e-file it's
possible he was preparing Bishop takes
e5 by my trying to not let the rook take
but I think it was called for anyway
right away so would have been what have
we been waiting for a very very long
time to do that we have mail to do yet
so finally it's time blacks unable to
capture and take the G file and we're
making threats against g6 and already I
think the game is beyond saving
so taking g6 twice isn't really a threat
just yet I would say I think black would
be more than happy to take a pond down
endgame yes instead of a five ok the
97th been suggested well Queen e7 and
after Knight f6 check we don't have a
hanging Bishop on d5 to take which is
kind of a problem mr. King f7 y can
resign so that's it's a good idea but
again gross trick really seems to or you
seem to have it down but at this point I
without a hanging bishop on g5 it's not
really working so h5 is it's very
consistent with the rest of White's play
you just want but finally it's it's been
a very controlled attack but the entire
time every single move the Chris trick
is made its purpose has been very clear
and it's been directed right at this guy
it's just been a little bit more
methodical but it's sort of more
barbaric way I was describing of
attacking at the beginning of the
lecture at this point gelfand felt
compelled to capture the 95 there's the
concession but it's very hard to suggest
another move all right
at this point we're nearing the
conclusion of White's efforts but still
it's not so easy to deliver checkmate
how are we going to bring the rest of
our pieces into the attack
well what other pieces do we have yeah
rookie three's been suggested this is
the best move well one of the two best
moves and the move order doesn't matter
between this and white snacks but it was
very simple why wants to put the hook on
g3 he's not ready for a move like H
takes g6 after hg queen g6
okay we're threatening a queen exchange
and it's gonna be very hard to avoid
after move like Queen here we're gonna
meet a pretty nasty respite with rook
takes c3 and all of a sudden it's gonna
be white it's a created we're not really
ready to crash through yet so we need to
bring more pieces in and indeed rookie 3
is the best way to do that so black
plays King h8 what's this plan with this
move yes
sure oh it's a ticket five first but
rook g8 has been suggested as blacks
plan entirely agree probably will take
h5 first but uh this is the general idea
so if black is able to just kind of put
stuff on the G file it's gonna be pretty
hard to made him so we have to be very
precise now with the good move here
white can prevent black from taking the
G file but there's only one way to do it
yes
Bishop g5 has been suggested with the
idea that's prophylaxis against rip g8
however it also puts the bishop on an
inferior square and in fact I think
black can even consider the move h6 here
which sacrifice doesn't even sacrifice
the pawn after G takes h5 but the point
the point is black will get the h7
Square first King which is going to be
very very helpful and then he can put
the rekon g8 so really the bishop on h6
was doing an excellent job of talking as
is so it's a good prophylactic idea but
regrettably it doesn't quite work here
calculate very precisely to prevent
black from technology file so if he
takes the G file as defensive chances go
way up if we take the G file he's
probably just checkmated yes
after age 66 the blacks whole idea was
to open the G file and here he's got his
wish
probably the Queen's are getting
exchanged right now seems like an issue
so you know we do want to make this move
happen sooner rather than later but at
this point we're not quite ready house
like in a yes queen h4 excellent so he's
putting a quit on a nice dark square and
after blacks rather obvious next move my
first of all should point out if rook g8
you know and so it was very not like
when you're attacking the whole goal is
to get to the king but you always have
to look for resources to transform the
game and in this case after Queen app
six takes takes Plex powerless to stop F
seven just kind of a nice trick to keep
in mind so rook GA doesn't work so black
plays G takes H five with the idea to
try to play riff g8 and contesse the G
file before y can made him there so
what's your what do yes
rook g3 so in a 48 right so this is very
positionally desirable for black to
start trading off pieces but the problem
is concretely he simply checkmate
rook takes g8 and Queens xg8 we have
Queen f6 with checkmate and if King
takes g8 we have Queen da with so blacks
unable to contest this G file which is a
real shame for him however even once we
took the G file precision is required
black now plays the move Bishop g5 and
White's next move which was found in
severe time pressure really put the
cherry on top of this game and it was an
unbelievable note how are we gonna
continue the attack here what's the best
way for whites a play this position
okay watch view of suggested rook g7
obviously I cannot permit this work to
stay here we're gonna get taken and my
question to you is explain to me why
this is not an immediate fortress well
why does the Queen but it's a queen for
a rook and Bishop and every single one
of blacks pawns is entirely safe
I think blacks drawing shadows is here
well over fifty percent i I don't really
see a way for whites to break through he
can't dislodge the bishop but rook comes
to c4 or something attacks the a4 upon
the c3 pond all black spawns are
protected and you can't undermine them
seems like a fortress
so why was not ready to cash in yet
obviously then the same response will be
met with Bishop g7 check black will
simply capture this bishop so it's not
so easy and the most obvious move seems
to Lee it's a very good drawing chances
for Blackman a probable fortress yes
enough six take and now up seven is
threatened but I think I can handle it
with you five
black seems to survive
maybe just barely but he does especially
when e5 is really well-placed defending
all the pawns defending this diagonal in
case needed but Queen f6 is an important
resource to keep in mind so at this
point yeah that's the question this is
always a question you should be asking
yourself whatever you play chess in any
position even when you seems like you're
the only one with the initiative like
you are here savelii valid question what
is my opponent's next move
sorry someone says slaughter what's
blacks next move here I can't hear
anyone yes I know that we got checkmated
like we just saw rook takes G rook g8 is
still impossible any kind of rope tricks
g8 so what is blocks next move
so the rook can't leave the
eighth-ranked it's among the squares on
the 8th Frank as long as G it's
unavailable probably see it's the best
square it's nope and file right so
what's Black's next books all species
are on their best course yeah B 5
something like this so a white can
prevent B 5 after a 5 ironically with
all the pieces on the board black is in
Zoo swamp he just he has to make a
suicidal move at this moment the problem
is he just has too many holes in his
position that need protecting the F 6
square needs constant attention because
Quay have six is checkmate the g7 square
needs attention because rook g7 or
Bishop g7 is made as long as black can't
sack the Queen the d8 Square needs
protection from this rook and lastly we
see if the rook moves away say rook e8
the C 4 square needs protection because
the bishop needs to stay on d5 if C for
this mission he's conveniently kicked
away and after something like Bishop c6
what does why play here yes right Queen
f6 and now we've we've kicked the bishop
away from this square what's able to
cash into this endgame and without the
e5 resource to defend f7 square white
just plays a7 and well either gives
checkmater once colossal online material
whichever you prefer so at this point a
5 was really the crowning move to top
off the game black just has no moves
here there's no way he can hold off
what's coming so
good let's say you were to play or
something like Bishop c4 and this is not
always played in the game but what's
just as sort of a exercise for you guys
how should white close this off
it's now blacks no longer in suits
what's next was Bishop back to d5 if you
do nothing which will improve his
position
well does the bishop gon g5 there
doesn't do on c4
it's not most relevant figure on the
right diagonal
exactly Bishop was protecting b7 when it
was on d5 so what should I play
right now why is able to break forth
rook g7 because if you fall asleep at
the wheel here for one moment and play
Queen 6 H 5 or something like this after
Bishop d5 black 5 is same fortress but
for one key move b7 is hanging and
that'll give white a pass C pawn and
that should easily win the game
so essentially white is gonna play rook
g7 it's just she couldn't do it last
time because black was set up a fortress
at this point no matter what black does
he's got to break his fortress in some
ways so golfin played the move out for
your saya gained some space for his
pieces
what's your white reacts
so someone suggest work tree seven yeah
rook g7 so at this point again we're
seeing the same thing we want this exact
same endgame but the big difference is I
mean here without this F pawn like what
will get f4 f5 in which will undermine
this Keith Bishop which defends
everything and make a passed pawn
completely lost
so rather than suffer through that
losing on game Kelvin tried to just sort
of hope for the best that he wouldn't
get shocked fated but well with all the
white pieces coming in and non elbow sac
it's a pretty meager hope so quite a 7.5
was played
alright game losses two more moves let's
find him
this point what piece of Lights is not
closer to that guess we need seven
excellent move bringing the Queen closer
to the attack and at this point the
simplest threat is rook g5 winning the
house so black doesn't really match for
that so he played queenie for keeping in
touch with h7 and threatening g2 rook g8
would be forced mate after rook takes g8
Queen f6 check but as his after Queen f6
okay girlfriend decided he'd seen enough
so it was one of my favorite games I've
ever seen it really demonstrated to me
just how different the attacks we see at
the really top level are from the
attacks we see I would say even at my
level even as a decent Grandmaster now I
mean I could not play a game like this I
really learned a lot from watching this
game and the kind of domination of the
dark square this brush took him with and
that Bishop before takes d5 maneuver
seems so counterintuitive bringing the
black Bishop to d5 and giving up the
bishop pair but well I wouldn't really
agree with the assessments of the
players after the game they both
immediately understood and said so after
the game at the position after Bishop
takes d5 Bishop 65.4 is hopeless for
black I think you had a bit more
defensive resources than that I think
it's not immediately lost but it's
really bad and it's really tough and I
personally think this was a very
exemplary model game by Chris Chuck so I
hope you enjoyed it as much as I did and
learned a lot from it
you